[Musik]
feiern und dazu zwang beim fingerhakeln
einer der besten josef putz schneider
braucht eigentlich beim fingerhakeln
geht es darum den anderen über den tisch
zu ziehen
kondition und anfänger ohne diesen
trainierten finger es ist eine
bayerische tradition früher ein
kräftemessen im wirtshaus heute ein
ernsthafter sport mit richtigen
meisterschaften
[Musik]
das interessante ist wenn einer da ist
ja wo alle kraft der welt hat aber heute
von kunden finger chor schnellkraft der
macht keinen stich
das macht die sportart eigentlich aus
dass man alles braucht und auf die
zehntelsekunde da sein muss auch das was
sonst zweier gehört blasmusik und bier
in reichertshofen bei nürnberg werden
die 61 bayerischen meisterschaften im
fingerhakeln ausgetragen rund 120
teilnehmer treten an und müssen sich
einem klaren regelwerk rügen unter den
augen von schiedsrichter helmut weiß
wir wollten uns mit dem mittelfinger und
sagen egal welchen fingern darauf erhält
darum wären nicht sagen dann wird mein
fuß den zug und wie schon reizen
und da kommt ihm das kommando eine
hacker fährt prinzip geht's los und
abzuwehren im zweiten bus 12 nehmen da
war sich der anfangs in mittel- und
gering
die hausgäste komische dinge erklären
dann ist aus
die meisterschaften finden immer im
wirtshaus oder festzelt statt
dementsprechend ist auch die stimmung
erste vorbereitung körperliche
grundlagen schaffen
josef schneider tritt in der
königsdisziplin an dem schwergewicht
[Musik]
im sechzehnten jahrhundert wurde das
fingerhakeln erstmals erwähnt damals
ging es darum streit zu schlichten oder
frauen zu imponieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auch der vorsitzende des fingerhakler
verbandes anton bader parkett mit
[Applaus]
dieser braucht um meine augen und auch
die kameradschaft und blumen beruf
stiegen auf
mit magnesia werden die finger kurz vor
dem kampf eingerieben damit sie trocken
bleiben und der makler ring nicht so
leicht abrutscht josef putz schneider
hat sich dafür eine richtige hornhaut an
trainiert
es geht jetzt darum dass man heute dass
man den finger auf betriebstemperatur
bringt uns aber beim hakeln kommt es
nicht nur auf den finger und die muskeln
an
mit ihm trennen wenn es wirklich wenn
zwar ganz gleichwertig ist ein und der
andere ist vom kopf her nicht so auf dem
sondern ist dieses entscheidet josefus
schneider ist seit zwölf jahren
ungeschlagener bayerischer deutscher und
alpenländischer meister auch hier macht
er mit seinen gegnern kurzen prozess
[Musik]
dollar
wird sie mal selbst machen aber es auf
jeden fall immer wieder spaß da
zuzuschauen
[Applaus]
auch im finale zieht josef schneider
seinen gegner über den tisch er ist
neuer und alter bayerischer meister
sein preisgeld ruhm ehre und die
kameradschaft unter den maklern das
fingerhakeln ein bayerisches brauchtum
das einfach unschlagbar ist
[Musik]